minimalism is about so much more than
just decoloring physical items from your
life it's about getting rid of the
excess so that you can make room for
what matters most to you in your life
but undoubtedly as your hobbies your
interests and just life in general
happens you will acquire more items and
so today i thought i'd take you along on
my monthly declutter and share with you
the 10 items that i'm going to be
declaring this month and why in case
you're feeling stuck in your
decluttering process or you just like to
start with minimalism and need some
ideas to figure out where to begin so
what i'll be doing is i'll first share
the item that i'm going to be getting
rid of and then i'll explain to you the
kind of category that you can look for
in your own home the first item on this
list for me is a faux leather case for
my pair of sheers now where this applies
to you would be pretty containers or
boxes for things that you purchase that
you don't need or you're not even using
but they're pretty boxes like your
iphone box you know a computer box that
you have lying around those sorts of
things you keep them because they're
good quality boxes and you don't want to
just throw them away but you're not
using them so in my case i had to
purchase a new pair of sheers this was
actually months ago because i do my own
hair my family's hair and i had kept the
case even though i could very well have
just put my shears in my own little
makeup pouch that saves me room it saves
me space and i don't have to get that
pouch and my makeup pouch when i'm doing
my eyebrows for example so look through
your house and look for any pretty boxes
or bags that you have no use for and
give yourself permission to get rid of
them the second one for me was actually
difficult for me to get rid of i went
back and forth and back and forth
whether or not i should do this and it's
unused electronics for me specifically a
gimbal for this youtube channel i had
purchased a very expensive gimbal the
zyun crane weeble lab i think it's
called and it is an awesome gimbal
however it didn't really fit my needs
for my lifestyle because it was
difficult to kind of balance it wasn't
difficult once i learned but it just it
required a lot of time and steps to take
it off the gimbal put it back on the
camera and maneuvering that with my kids
and my full-time job it just it didn't
work out i never ever used it because
it's so much easier for me to use this
selfie stick which i actually have right
here but it's extendable and it's
foldable and just so much nicely
in a bag versus having a gimbal while
carrying around kids and running after
them it didn't work and so i had to kind
of give myself the forgiveness that i
purchased this expensive item and didn't
use it so for you what this could be is
items that you have purchased and spent
a lot of money on but you know you're
not going to be using them sometimes
when we purchase really expensive items
and then we don't end up using them we
attach guilt to it and that's what keeps
us from getting rid of it to begin with
because we feel almost like we're gonna
lose money if we get rid of that item
but see the thing is we've already spent
that money that money's already gone so
what i did with my gimbal is i sold it
online of course i didn't make the same
amount of money that i paid for it to
begin with but at least i know that now
it will go to a home where it will
actually be used this next one is big
bulky furniture or furniture that you're
not using my husband had made this chest
well i guess it's a media console back
when we had a tv and he used to play
video games we don't have either of them
anymore and we didn't have a use for it
however we still had it up in our attic
for two years because hey maybe someday
we'll need it or maybe someday we'll use
it my sister had actually just moved out
recently and so we gifted it to her
sometimes though big bulky items if you
just keep them in your house you're
gonna find something to put inside them
and not only that but it's just causing
a lot of clutter in your home think of
the amount of space that they're taking
up that you could have opened up if you
would get rid of some of these items so
look around and see what kind of big
bulky furniture pieces maybe you can get
rid of this next one is a black fancy
dress it's one of those items that i
think it's just nice for me to look at
however i never really gravitate towards
because if i wear it i feel like i'm
maybe too dressed up or too
uncomfortable it's maybe a little too
snug here it's pretty to look at but i
don't wear it and so those sorts of
items really shouldn't belong in your
closet all the clothes that you have
should make you feel good should
accentuate the best parts of you try to
get rid of those maybe someday items
next we head off to the kitchen and this
is the category of food food that you're
never going to eat so i was recently on
the keto diet and i had purchased a
whole bunch of things specifically for
that that i didn't really end up using
and so i decided that i was going to
donate these to someone else that would
use them but look around too at things
that have been expired or things that
you bought because you were gonna make
that one specialty item and then you
realize yeah that's not gonna happen
consider getting rid of those this next
one for me is moonshine and i'm not
really one that really typically drinks
alcohol but i had recently been in
tennessee and tennessee is very well
known for its moonshine and because i
was on the keto diet at that time i
couldn't try it and they had a chocolate
coffee moonshine and i love chocolate
and coffee and i was just curious about
what they're well known for and so i
decided i'm gonna take one home and just
try it at home and see what it's like
and then i got home and i tried it it
just
it was strong stuff it just was not for
me and so i had kept it and i've tried
it and i'd sip it every now and then and
then i'd realize i'm not gonna drink
this this is not for me it's not my
thing i tried it okay i didn't like it
it's fine i can let it go so yeah i
poured it down the drain so i guess
where this can apply as a category for
things that you can look for in your own
home is those items that you decided you
were going to try but then you didn't
end up liking don't keep those if it's
not for you it's not something that you
enjoy give yourself permission to get
rid of it this next one is paper related
and i had recently gotten rid of our
vitamix recipe book because i realized
that i am not one that will typically
follow a recipe anyway and even though
this book was really beautiful and it
felt kind of soft on the front it had
beautiful pictures i realized if i'm not
ever going to use it i shouldn't just
keep it boxed up and taking up space in
our home and then also we have an
espresso machine that i had the manual
for manuals you can download pretty much
anything online or just look up a
youtube video on how to do something
which is typically what i go to that is
actually how i figured out how to clean
the machine was a youtube video maybe
it's not the wisest idea i don't know
let me know in the comments do you read
manuals or don't you these next two
items are old hobbies or things that i
know that i used to love that i don't
anymore so for me i used to really enjoy
chalk painting that furniture piece that
i actually showed you was one that i
painted and i enjoyed that i love that i
still really enjoy painting but not
shopping
painting homes renovating kind of thing
and so i had all of these paints that i
knew that i wasn't going to be using
because i hadn't used them in years and
so it was time for them to find a new
home and same thing goes with some cake
decorating supplies i had had an
assortment of things because i know how
to decorate cakes i had taken classes
before i can make flowers and pretty
designs and it's something that i
enjoyed years ago but it's not something
that i enjoy now i would much rather pay
somebody money to make me a cake now
than for me to make it myself it's just
not enjoyable anymore when i was getting
rid of these items it actually was it
was hard because it was almost like
letting go of a piece of my past and so
i had to kind of get around that by
telling myself getting rid of these
items doesn't mean that it's getting rid
of my past getting rid of my memories i
can still hold on to those memories take
pictures or videos of things that i have
done in the past and so i can keep those
without keeping the physical items so
maybe if you had hobbies that you no
longer enjoy consider maybe taking a
photo or video of them so that you can
kind of have a way to keep a memory of
them without actually keeping that item
this next category may not apply to you
but that is kids toys inevitably kids
just tend to acquire more toys even
though we haven't purchased toys for
them in a while and so periodically i
just kind of go throughout the house and
check for those toys that never get
played with if i do think that they just
haven't played with them in a while but
they may play with them again what i'll
do is i'll just box them up in a closet
for a few months and then take them out
and do what's called a toy rotation
where i take out some toys and give them
other toys that way i don't have so much
clutter and at the same time they get
kind of new toys every few months and
that is the 10 items that i am
decluttering this month i hope that in
sharing this it's been helpful to you
and given you some ideas of things that
you can get rid of so that you can make
room for what matters most in your life
thank you so much for watching if you
found this video helpful please give it
a thumbs up and subscribe so you won't
miss when i post a new video i'll see
you in the next one bye